all right now a big developing story out
of Los Angeles tonight where Democratic
La mayoral candidate Karen bass says
multiple Firearms were stolen from her
home in a break-in on Saturday bass said
in a statement quote at this time it
appears that only two Firearms despite
being safely and securely stored were
stolen cash Electronics of the valuables
were not and it's unnerving and
unfortunately it's something that far
too many angelenos have faced now bass a
former congressman is a staunch gun
control Advocate and this summer even
boasted about her commitment to
targeting law-abiding gun owners
tweeting quote I am the only 2022 Moms
Demand Action Gun sense candidate
running for mayor of Los Angeles Los
Angeles deserves a mayor that we can
trust and stand up to the gun lobby not
cower before them and while in Congress
bass also co-sponsored a resolution that
urged states to repeal stand your ground
laws of among a Litany of other far left
gun positions and now she wants to
double down on all those four left
failures and become mayor of Los Angeles
so pass is fine keeping guns for herself
if they were secure she said but wants
to make it harder for law-abiding
citizens in Los Angeles to exercise
their second amendment rights here with
reaction Leo 2.0 Terrell long without
kick founder clay Travis you know Leo
let me look at this from the legal side
so she had these had these securely and
safely stored guns robbed but they
didn't take cash they didn't take other
valuables they didn't take electronics
why is my antenna up really really high
and my BS Adam Schiff meter spinning
around in circles in my head like a
siren get that antenna get that 18 up a
little higher because I'll tell you why
is it about what 60 days before a
midterm election where she's trying to
become a the first black female mayor of
Los Angeles and we know how race and
color has nothing to do with
qualification see our vice president see
our White House Press Secretary I don't
buy this story she she's robbed at the
uh and the the the the the the robber
only takes these two guns and they
Brinks lock box I don't buy this and I
think what is happening here is she is
getting a message out there that she's
against guns Sean she also said earlier
this year on a scale of one to ten it's
a 10 as far as her safety in Los Angeles
she's on a different Universe Los
Angeles is not safe she supports George
gascon she supports black lives matter
she supports antifa where was her in the
summer of 2020 riots she was supporting
the Riders this woman is a disaster and
remember she was very close to being
vice president what did her in because
she thought Castro was a great leader
this woman is horrible for Los Angeles
she's horrible for the country and she
must be living a multi-universe because
Los Angeles is not safe
so we're supposed to believe the
Firearms were safely and securely stored
clay Travis but they didn't steal
anything else
um that makes me very suspicious in and
of itself and then she supports getting
rid of stand your ground laws around the
country and I'm wondering okay so what
did you have the firearms in her house
for uh was she going to retreat with her
weapon and say pretty please leave my
house is that was that her plan because
that doesn't make sense either to me
luckily
Leo knows what's going on in LA right
now is la is so unsafe that people are
actually being followed to their homes
and when they arrive at their house
criminals are following them inside and
I'm so sick of this it is infuriating
every city in America the people who are
telling you how safe the city is pay for
their own private security they have
their own armed guards and they want to
tell everybody out there oh you don't
have the right to protect yourself do
you know how many Suburban women right
now do you know how many people of color
you go look at who's buying guns right
now it's not your white guys out there
who are driving so many of these firearm
cells it's women who feel threatened in
their cities no matter where they go
like this poor woman Eliza Fletcher who
went for a jog in Memphis and got
kidnapped while she was out jogging by
the University of Memphis it's all these
women all over the country it's a lot of
minorities whose communities are unsafe
because of Paul politicians like this
lecturing us and saying your cities are
safe and they're living like Hypocrites
they have tons of guns themselves they
have all the armed security they want uh
Leo how many times we heard Corey Bush
say you got to defend the police she's
out here spending 500 Grand on her own
private security but they're rich enough
for your own private security detail you
don't need the police I ask anybody what
are you going to do God forbid and we
have an increase in the murder rate
crime rate all across the country right
now because a defund dismantle Nobel
what are people going to do that are
anti-gun if God forbid somebody breaks
into your house and wants to bring harm
to you and your family I know what I'm
going to do I'm going to defend myself
and my family what what do these people
have to defend themselves nothing Leo
uh and basically what they want they
want civil unrest they want citizens who
depend on the police to become
Vigilantes we're going to take matters
in our own hands and that's chaos Sean
they are basically providing a
prescription for chaos because without
these supporting the police by basically
allowing criminals to roam the street
and terrorize they're basically telling
citizens fend for yourself and that's
what's going to happen in results civil
disorder what what do you do if you
don't have any type of weapon clay
you're a Sitting Duck if the police
response t as time is low you still you
you're doomed whatever's going to happen
happen
well they'll tell you what you're
supposed to do is call a social worker
and they'll just tell the criminal that
they feel sorry that the criminal is
behaving so violently and try to talk
him out of uh committing a crime of
violence and then you know what's going
to happen to me and they get arrested
yeah please don't shoot somebody and
then they get sent right back out on the
streets they're barely in prison at all
I feel bad for so many of our police out
there working as hard as they can they
get bad guys arrested the people who are
committing the crimes and then they're
back out on the streets thanks to people
like Kamala Harris almost as soon as
they get arrested all right clay Travis
thank you Leo 2.0 Terrell thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else